[Musique]
Émilie Nicolas Michel soget Christian
Dufour bonsoir
tout à l'heure avec Valérie Mika et la
benne je me suis lancé dans une image en
disant monsieur Trudeau a reçu ses
cadeaux de Noël avant le temps parce
qu'aujourd'hui à la commission rouleau
il faut le rappeler à chaque fois pour
les gens la commission qui doit
déterminer est-ce que Monsieur Trudeau
avait absolument besoin de faire appel à
la loi des mesures d'urgence la loi
d'exception à tawa pour mettre fin au
blocus des camionnettes et du pont quoi
que le pont ça va être réglé avant mais
bref avait-il besoin le chef du SARS est
venu dire c'est moi qui l'a demandé en
pendant un conseil des ministres Michel
c'est Auger là Monsieur Trudeau là on
pourrait questionner ce que dit Monsieur
Vignaud mais monsieur Trudeau vient de
sortir la pression baisser là
un petit peu parce que le directeur du
STRs ça veut dire contraire un moment
donné il faut pas l'oublier alors
et ça la personne qui se trouve dans une
mauvaise situation c'est juste ou non
parce que la distinction qui doit faire
entre est-ce que c'était utile c'est
simplement utile c'est pas nécessaire
devient un petit peu plus compliqué
qu'avant avec ce témoignage alors il va
falloir voir comment ça va jouer mais
c'est clair que voici quelqu'un qui de
au début avait l'air de dire c'était pas
nécessaire puis là maintenant devant le
cabinet moi j'ai dit OK dans la
situation où c'est en train de se
développer ça devient nécessaire
vendredi écoutez même si j'avais eu des
doutes et j'avais peut-être des doutes
le patron du RS me dit devant tous mes
ministres tu dois faire ça vous devez
faire ça ça le dédouane un peu non c'est
sûr que ça le dédouane mais en même
temps c'est assez c'est assez compliqué
parce que essentiellement la loi toutes
les mesures d'urgences que ça dit c'est
ça définit une menace à la sécurité
nationale selon la définition du SARS
puis essentiellement ce que le directeur
est allé dire ce que ce que Monsieur
vigno est allé dire c'est que notre
définition peut-être que c'est pas ce
qui est le convoi à t'avoir rendre
compte dans cette définition là mais il
y a d'autres définitions d'une menace à
la sécurité nationale avec son valides
donc essentiellement est en train de
dire que selon nos responsabilités ça
rentre pas dans le critère mais selon
des critères politiques plus larges ça
pourrait rentrer donc on est encore dans
quelque chose qui est assez
difficile de juger c'est comme si on est
en train de dire que la loi sur sur les
mesures d'urgence aurait dû être écrit
autrement et que on l'a évoquait en se
disant qu'il faudrait qu'elle soit écrit
autrement donc est-ce que est-ce qu'on
était justifié de l'invoquer rendu là ça
reste encore une zone grise donc oui
effectivement un peu comme Michel le
disait ça va être compliqué surtout pour
le juge de démêler tout ça dans son
rapport de commission mais imaginez
Christian s'il avait témoigné
moi je leur ai dit que c'était pas
absolument nécessaire mais il faisait de
s'arrêter de s'arrêter beaucoup plus
problématique pour le gouvernement
n'est-ce pas oui c'est vrai mais il
reste que c'est pas lui qui avait décidé
c'est pas un ministre qui avait décidé
et moi je trouve que il était pas obligé
de décider là c'est tellement important
comme précédemment l'évocation de cette
loi-là je trouve que il faut vraiment
garder
la marge de manœuvre que le premier
ministre avait c'est un peu facile de
dire le premier c'est pas le choix il y
avait le choix non non il y avait le
choix
c'est trop facile de dire ça discute et
ce que je viens de dire Émilie Nicolas
est important il y a un glissement qui
est troublant dans ce que dit Monsieur
Vigneau c'est que là on nous parle de la
loi des mesures d'urgence et puis au
départ on avait l'impression que c'était
quand la sécurité nationale était
menacée mais non disant quelque chose de
nouveau qui est arrivé dans le contexte
de la pandémie on interprétation
différente ça semble viser les
complotistes tout compte fait moi je
trouve ça troublant reste à faire là
parce que faut jamais oublier qu'on
parle d'une mesure d'exception et puis
c'est le premier ministre qui est
responsable de cette maison mais est-ce
que nous n'avions pas devant nous puis
on l'a couvert à tous les jours puis nos
journalistes une manifestation
d'exception qui paralysait le
centre-ville de la capitale canadienne
en fait c'est qu'il fait référence à des
discours idéologiques qui pouvaient
inciter peut-être des gens à la violence
et un côté un peu nébuleux là-dedans moi
c'est un moment personnellement pour
être franc bon moi ça avoue ce que ça
vaut mais moi en suivant ça je trouve
que c'était pas nécessaire d'invoquer
cette loi-là et Monsieur vigno a jeté un
élément nouveau qui est troublant et un
glissement là c'est comme si cette loi
d'exception là on l'a adapté entre dans
l'interprétation au contexte de la
pandémie essentiellement compter les
complotistes donc c'est important ce qui
est arrivé ici et on est ailleurs on
n'est pas dans l'interprétation
traditionnelle de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence et de la sécurité nationale et
Monsieur Trudeau garde sa pleine
responsabilité c'est lui qui est
prédiction bien sûr c'est lui le Premier
ministre c'est le cabinet qui ont pris
la décision Michel Soger Milly Nicolas
par ailleurs il dit parce qu'on peut lui
demander monsieur Vignaud comment se
fait-il que le renseignement Canadien
n'avait pas vu les ramifications que ça
allait être pas mal plus gros qu'on
pensait et là il dit ben non pas
vraiment le Michel
c'est ça il avait déjà dit que à son
avis c'était pas nécessaire là il change
sa version en disant ah il y avait plein
de de d'autres facteurs mais il y a
plein de gens si je me souviens bien la
police d'Ottawa a dit que c'est pas
nécessaire
la sûreté de l'Ontario elle dit la même
chose à un moment donné c'est pas c'est
la le choix de la nécessité politique
est évidemment celui du Premier ministre
et ça il vivra avec les conséquences de
ça mais comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure le juge rouleau lui a un mandat
de tranchées nécessaires ou pas il va se
baser ces témoignages et il y a des
témoignages des deux côtés mais c'est
clair que le premier conseiller du
gouvernement dans ces matières là ça
reste le CRS et que là on a le directeur
du CNS qui dit ok c'était la chose à
faire
le cabinet ok Émilie est-ce que ça peut
mal tourner quand même
et mettre en lumière des décisions ou
une instrumentalisation pour reprendre
un mois à la mode du gouvernement
Trudeau de cette colère là je pense que
il semble avoir tellement de lignes
grises de zone grise que les gens qui
étaient convaincus qu'il y avait raison
d'invoquer la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence ou inconvue qu'il y avait fait
la bonne chose et les gens qui étaient
contre qui trouvaient que c'était
exagéré vont continuer à penser que
c'était contre parce qu'il y a tellement
d'éléments ça va tellement être
difficile à trancher puis il faut
rappeler c'est ça en fait la question du
jeu chez est-ce que la loi sur la mesure
d'urgence c'était pertinente d'invoquer
mais la commission soulève d'autres
questions qui sont pas les questions que
le jeu je dois répondre donc est-ce que
la police est en train de faire son
travail correctement et c'est ça un peu
le piège dans lequel probablement que le
gouvernement s'est retrouvé c'est que si
la GRC les autres services de police
surtout les services de police d'Ottawa
avait fait son travail autrement dès le
début les choses serait pas monter
jusque là la loi est écrit d'une manière
ou essentiellement c'est comme si ça
prévoit un monde magique où toutes les
institutions fonctionnent comme elles le
devrait alors que c'est absolument pas
ça qu'on a vu et que c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il y avait des trous au niveau des
renseignements importants on a vu la
semaine passée les les services de
police des différentes provinces qui se
parlent pas qui échangent pas
l'information tout ça a été relevé aussi
par la commission conclusion Christian
brièvement bon ça va être très important
en fait ce rapport-là il va falloir le
lire parce qu'il faut jamais oublier le
précédent c'est ça qui est troublant moi
quant à moi c'est le précédent que ça
crée cette évocation là on peut
discerner sur des matérialiser des
détails mais c'est un précédent qui est
inquiétant pour les libertés publiques
très bien d'autant que c'est parce qu'on
invoque cette loi on est obligé de faire
cet exercice là tellement que c'est un
outil qu'on ne veut pas utiliser
normalement ok bon les statues les
statues qui reviennent
on va voir des images c'est en nous 2020
un groupe de manifestants à faire
renverse la statue de Johnny mec dans
l'eau le premier ministre du Canada et
sa tête rôle parce que sa tête avait
déjà été décapité lors d'une autre
manifestation et un comité
recommande à la ville voilà sa tête un
comité recommande à la Ville de Montréal
de ne plus jamais remettre la statue sur
le choc et de d'inscrire une plaque en
disant quelque chose comme autrefois il
y avait une statue et voici pourquoi il
n'y a plus de statue Émilie Nicolas en
toute transparence on va parler vous
êtes libre mais
votre conjoint était sur ce comité-là de
la ville on le dit là effectivement donc
je vais rentrer dans Johnny le
McDonald's mais je vais peut-être pas
parler de la vie comme tel
mais de façon générale vous vous êtes
d'accord ou bien le comité peut se
déballeur ferrage depuis des années vous
êtes d'accord qu'on a réinstalle pas ces
statuts vous Émilie mais je pense que
souvent la manière de ce débat là au
lieu c'est comme si d'un côté on est
posé les gens qui étaient pour
l'histoire pour la mémoire historique et
les gens qui étaient contre l'histoire
contre la mémoire historique et je pense
que c'est pour ça que ce genre de débat
là d'érable je pense que depuis en fait
que la station est tombée non seulement
c'est à Montréal mais aussi les statues
de journées McDonald's les édifices au
nom de Jamel John McDon on peut partout
au pays depuis que ces édifices sont en
question que les statuts sont en
question ne jamais autant parlé
publiquement de l'histoire de Johny
McDonald on n'a jamais rappelé
publiquement tout ce qu'il a fait y
compris les parts de l'histoire beaucoup
plus sombre très traumatique ou beaucoup
communautés au Canada qui avait été
souvent laissé dans l'ombre donc j'ai
l'impression que c'est des fois c'est en
enlevant la statue qu'on est en train en
fait de rappeler la mémoire et
l'histoire canadienne en toute sa
complexité et si ce qui est mis de
l'avant au bout non seulement du comité
de la vie des experts mais aussi des
consultations auprès de la population de
la ville de Montréal c'est une solution
qui fait en sorte qu'on continue à faire
ce travail-là d'éducation populaire sur
l'histoire du Canada dans toute sa
complexité pas seulement les bouts qui
font plaisir aux mythe fondateur je
pense que je pense qu'on va avoir avancé
dans dans la compréhension de l'histoire
il faut rappeler Michel Cyr ce qu'on
reproche à Johnny mcdonal le bon premier
premier ministre du Canada per
Confédération mais avec des politiques
extrêmement violentes envers les
Premières nations entre c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui qui ne passe pas et donc
plusieurs groupes différents de plein de
mouvances on dit on veut plus voir à
Victoria on l'a enlevé devant l'hôtel de
ville on veut plus voir à Montréal bon
Michel Saugier ça c'est le contexte
historique à Montréal il y avait une
décision à prendre est-ce qu'on la remet
ou pas qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
moi je suis d'accord avec l'idée de ne
pas la remettre de toute façon il y
aurait eu une manifestation dans le même
atteindre leur a fait une autre fois
c'est évident
il va falloir garder le monument lui on
le garde on met une explication devant
et la station on peut on peut la donner
il y a quelques musées historiques à
Montréal la pointe acadière
ou quelqu'un comme ça et qu'il a dit
qu'il la met trop quelque part avec une
explication aussi historique et des
événements mais en même temps moi je
veux quand même dire là on ouvre une
canne de verre qu'est-ce qu'on fait je
vous donne un exemple je vais partir à
un autre de bas mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de dollars des hormones pas que la
fontaine
alors si on parle là-dessus ça va être
long longtemps de Nelson
[Musique]
donc c'est un symbole identifaire qu'on
le veuille ou non j'en ai McDonald's
c'est pas juste le traitement inique à
l'égard des autochtones et si on se
lance dans cette dynamique là mais moi
je trouve qu'on devrait élargir le
mandat du comité pour étudier les bilan
de 30 personnes les 30 premiers minutes
du Canada je suis en 1976 en 1986 pardon
c'est en 1985 qui est disparu le dernier
pensionnat autochtone moi je trouve que
c'est une voix qui nous mène nulle part
et c'est inquiétant le passé existe
l'histoire existe au fil de l'arrivée ce
qu'on va voir c'est juste une grosse
statue où ça va être écrit nous
maintenant nous sommes les seuls à
exister le patient veut rien savoir le
passé si un taux de leçon dans le passé
et je répète on sait devant cède à la
pression donc vous avez compris mon
point de vue Emilie à cet argument là
qui dit jusqu'où ça parce qu'on peut il
y a plein de personnages là qui sont
des personnages impeccables dans
l'histoire il y en a pas de temps que ça
si on alors on met la ligne puis est-ce
que c'est possédé aussi à une forme de
balance là mais en fait il y a deux
arguments qui reviennent souvent le
premier je l'ai déjà abordé l'histoire
de essentiellement les gens sont contre
l'histoire le deuxième Christian vient
de le nommer celui que faut pas juger
les gens du passé aux valeurs à la
lumière des valeurs d'aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est important entre de
rappeler que les communautés autochtone
étaient contre leur propre extermination
au 19e siècle je pense que c'est
important de rappeler que les
populations chinoises canadiennes
d'origine chinoise au Canada était
contre les taxes d'entrée qui leur
empêché de voir leur famille pendant des
générations au 19e siècle je pense que
c'est important de rappeler que les gens
qui étaient pas des personnes blanches
au Canada était contre la suprématie
blanche que j'en ai mis dans l'ordre
mettait de l'avant Parlement canadien au
19e siècle donc je pense que des les
canadiens francophones qui ont été
blessés par beaucoup de politiques de
Jean-Louis McDonald on était contre
Johnny McDonald au 19e siècle et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi ça a tellement fait
de bruit au 19e siècle la pendaison
notamment de Louis viel est-ce que sa
représentait notamment pour les
francophones au Québec et pour les
métiers donc franchement l'idée de dire
que Johnny McDonald's c'est d'être
contre une partie de son héritage c'est
de faire un anachronisme je pense qu'il
faut vraiment se replacer dans le
contexte du 19e siècle et se dire que
c'est voilà au 19e siècle elle n'était
pas entendu dans les décisions qu'on a
eu des médicaments exactement
à l'époque ont pas été entendu c'est pas
seulement les voix aujourd'hui c'est les
voix de l'époque il y avait pas été
entendues dans la décision même de
mettre tous ses
pas été juste ça c'est ça c'est clair
que son Bilal il garde des autochtones
est unique comme le bilan de tous les
gens de l'époque et de tous les premiers
d'une certaine façon qui ont cautionné
ça mais j'en ai mais il y en a ça a pas
été juste ça je suis d'accord avec
Christian c'est pour ça qu'il faut se
rappeler de la personne mais il y a une
différence entre rappeler d'une personne
et de son importance et la célébrer et
la glorifier et c'est ça qu'on fait en
mettant des statues dans l'espace public
je vous demande de répondre à votre
propre question on s'arrête tout là à
quel moment ça devient tolérable une
statut pour quelqu'un il y en a
plusieurs à Montréal j'en ai nommé
quelques-unes
c'est extrêmement difficile et ça c'est
un débat qu'on doit avoir
moi sur la question de John je trouve
que c'est justifié je trouve pas que ça
serait justifié partout et dans toutes
les circonstances mais à un moment donné
il va falloir qu'on regarde ça avec une
série de critères relativement objectifs
à dire voici quelle est la par exemple
la politique de la Ville de Montréal la
politique du gouvernement du Québec sur
ces choses-là parce qu'à un moment donné
les c'est vrai que les statuts aussi
peuvent servir à
de du traficotage partisan quand
monsieur l'évêque avait sorti la statue
de Duplessis juste avant le référendum
pour essayer de mettre un national dans
sa petite poche pour le référendum
c'est ça qui faisait on va passer le
cacher alors un moment donné
toutes ces choses là ont souvent des
motifs qui sont pas nécessairement les
motifs de vérification de dire premier
Premier ministre de l'histoire du Canada
donc il faut faire quelque chose
c'est des motifs qui sont beaucoup plus
contemporains est-ce qu'il y aurait
moyen qu'on décroche un peu du passé
puisqu'on s'intéresse au présent et à
l'avenir qu'est-ce que ça va changer
concrètement dans la situation
déplorable des autochtones ou souvent
dans les réserves ont même pas d'eau moi
là je suis capable des gens qui sont pas
capables de décrocher du passé on peut
rien changer au passé le passé et le
passé quand même qu'on déboulonnerait
toutes les statues Louis XIV Louis XIV
mais Donald respect vous comprenez moi
je trouve que c'est un geste
d'impuissance on est dans le symbole
qu'on s'occupe donc du présent et du de
l'avenir des gens qui sont discriminés
et qui sont maltraités au Canada c'est
ça l'important c'est pas des déboulonner
les statuts Emilie pour Janet vous dit
dans votre esprit c'est clair et net
est-ce que il y a pas des cas où on peut
être plus déchirés là c'est pas si
simple absolument c'est pour ça que
à la fin de toutes séduction là
l'important c'est pas ce que j'en pense
ou ce que Michel en pense que ça en
pense c'est ce que les Montréal et les
Montréalais en pensent parce que c'est
de ça dont il est question
un monument sur l'espace public la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire avec notre espace public dans un
parc au milieu du centre-ville qu'est-ce
qu'on veut avoir là c'est ça la question
qui est posée par la consultation puis
je pense qu'effectivement il y a des il
y a des symboles il y a des gens qui
peuvent être posés dans les espaces
publics pour faire en sorte que les gens
s'approprient ces espaces là puis il y
en a qui qui qui font l'inverse puis
c'est pour ça que effectivement il y
aura jamais une ligne très claire on est
effectivement dans des engrais sur
certains cas puis je pense que le
quartier là elle est continuellement
taché de peinture et est-ce qu'on doit
enlever genre j'étais le quartier aussi
mais ça dépend
on va faire des procès aujourd'hui en
fait des procès aux personnages
historiques du passé
toutes les statues parce qu'elles ont
été mises là une fois on peut avoir un
débat mais je savais pas dire qu'on se
capte tout le temps alors ça c'est pas
la même chose heureusement mais dans
certains cas il y a des heureux mais
dans d'accord on a le droit de
s'interroger sur la pertinence d'une
statue dans le film
faut dire quand on lit sur quand il a
été érigé ça avait été dans la
controverse là
les gens le peuple de Montréal avait pas
acclamé ça cette statue-là depuis le
jour 1 en fait qui a eu des problèmes
avec Johnny mcdonaux ce qui n'enlève pas
sa place
est-ce que ça ne tue pas la mémoire
est-ce que ça aboutit pas aux résultats
inverse de ce livre qui recherchent
parce que
c'est pas comme une statue sur une place
publique c'est que ça tu l'as ça
tous les gens qui se lancent l'histoire
ce que je veux juste dire c'est que ces
statut-là de personnages qui sont par
définition controversées c'est des gens
du passé on est en train de faire le
procès à des gens du passé il reste
qu'il nous raconte quelque chose qui est
aussi mauvais il me semble j'aime
beaucoup mieux moi des plaques
expliquatives ce genre de débat mais pas
moi je trouve ça barbare des Boulonnais
des statuts pour être franc je trouve
c'est une régression civilisation donc
Emilie avec une plaque qui aurait
expliqué son rôle dans sa relation avec
les peuples autochtones par exemple qui
aurait mis en contexte et que c'est pas
des historiens vous dites même pas parce
que le remède sur le chat vous êtes trop
là c'est une insulte mais c'est pas moi
de le dire je pense que c'est au
communauté autochtone à dire ceci dit je
pense que beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
d'éléments à explorer puis je suis sûr
que les gens qui connaissent uniquement
on regardait toutes les toutes les
options possibles je pense que c'est
possible par exemple je pense qu'on a
déjà mentionné pour la statue d'être non
réparée et d'être dans un musée puis
qu'on parle par exemple de de ce qu'elle
aurait présenté à la base est-ce que
toutes les manifestations qui ont eu
comme son existence veulent aussi dire
sur l'histoire du Canada parce que
lorsqu'on parle d'histoire c'est aussi
l'histoire contemporaine si il y a ce
genre de mouvement-là je sais pas
combien de fois la statue a été
vandalisée vandalisée vandalisé
critiquer puis c'est pas seulement le
bandaliste je sais pas il y a combien eu
de lettre ouverte dans les journaux
parler de cette statue là aussi au fil
du temps de l'héritage de Johnny
McDonald au fil du temps donc c'est tout
ça je pense que il pourrait avoir sa
place dans son musée peut-être plus que
dans un parc où il y a pas de service
interprétation disponible pour les gens
qui veulent vraiment s'informer sur son
histoire merci pour ce dernier de toutes
les cannes de verre c'est un beau débat
c'est un beau débat non non mais merci
merci à vous trois pour vrai bonne
soirée à très bientôt bonne soirée au
revoir